first up he is the writer director and
producer of the film belfast nominated
for seven academy awards one of my
favorites kenneth runner is here
wow
thank you sir
what a great pleasure i mean
so sincerely thank you i appreciate that
thank you
welcome to america thank you very much
and i i want americans to see your movie
because it's a fantastic movie thank you
very much thank you uh but i feel like
we need to set it up because americans
they're not great on history
you know as most historical movies
when they make them for the american
audience they put like a crawl at the
beginning of the movie you know in 1378
france was under the rule of because
otherwise andy yeah well they just don't
know that's not our big thing it's like
the present and old-timey days
i think i think we're a lot like you to
be really okay so i'm gonna like do the
geography and then i want you to do the
history i think people know that there's
england they can picture that and next
to that the island the
island of ireland
i don't think they understand sometimes
that
england is really the uk the united
kingdom made of four provinces england
is one of them scotland wales and then
northern ireland is a piece of ireland
but it's part of the uk and that's where
the heartaches begin yeah so we'll put
okay so we're talking about 1968 your
childhood when the troubles began
because in that northern ireland part
which again part of england half
catholic half protestant unlike
ireland itself which is all catholic
okay
why did it start why they lived together
for a long time protestants and
catholics in belfast why did it start
then
well just like in your country in the
mid 60s you'll know much better than
either there was a civil rights movement
and that was definitely on the streets
in the north of ireland and that was
expressing the the dissatisfaction of
the in the north as you rightly say the
minority catholic population who
believed that they were not uh
free to the same kind of social and
economic opportunities as the dominant
protestant population of the uk
controlled north so that was expressed
the assertion of those rights was
expressed through the civil rights
movement from the mid 60s onwards by 69
august 1569 when the events at the
beginning of this film unfold
it spills into violence violence that in
the case of my own particular story was
in one street one neighborhood we were
mainly protestants in that street
probably 70 30 but we loved our catholic
neighbors and we got on with our
catholic neighbors with the same size
houses with the same kinds of jobs we
did the same kind of things and uh but
in one fell swoop a protestant mob came
down the street marked the houses of the
catholics with stones they broke the
windows essentially said we know where
you live time to get out and then what
followed in that awful august of 69 the
summer of love here there was the
biggest displacement of um population in
a european city since the end of the
second world war and hundreds of
thousands of catholics were forced to
move and there was a population
rearrangement which began as you say a
dark dark period in the history of that
part of the world of thirty years of the
day and it's so interesting i mean the
way you bring it home in a very human
way that everybody can relate to is
because i mean you're a protestant
family yeah and and you had good parents
they're kind of around being my parents
and you mentioned the civil rights where
i lived in a house that i thought was a
bit of an outlier in the 60s an
all-white town but my parents made me
understand when i was a kid what was it
what was right and wrong what was going
on in america with civil rights and your
parents sort of did the same thing i
mean because people came and threatened
you
you're protestant they wanted to get rid
of the catholics and people came to your
father and said you're either with us or
against us okay there's no there's no
being in the middle here and your father
stood up to that well tried to and
people did try and try to and in the
subsequent period people tried to live
what you might call a sort of
independent existence where that really
difficult thing to do of disagreeing
fundamentally with someone
not translating to then hating them or
rejecting them but doing the even more
difficult thing of actually trying to
understand them that was what well the
example he said
and also doing
the difficult thing
when people become tribal which is what
we have here in america the very
difficult thing which what we try to do
here on this show to
sometimes no success at all
of trying to say i'm not with either
tribe yeah i'm thinking for myself yeah
about this issue yeah i'm not going to
join with you because you hate the
catholics for reasons i do not and that
seems to be what your
you know your father and your mother are
telling you in this movie and a
nine-year-old has to be taught that it
does have to be taught that but and also
you have to you know so much as you say
that is in between
uh is is that gray area and the reason
we told the story of this
of this family's journey through the
eyes of a nine-year-old is that often we
forget that that child's eye view of the
world
which is a useful place to see the world
from sometimes not to be naive and
sentimental but because there's a
simplicity to it that i think is very
pure and can be very open but it's also
the price that is paid when violence
comes to visit is that you know uh that
things not only get polarized but the
the people whose lives will be forever
affected by it you know across decades
and decades of whatever you might call
it damage or psychic baggage or trauma
or whatever it might be which also has
long-term domino knocking over effect i
think
is what gets lost in the immediate kind
of
standoff that is sometimes you know
polarizing and it can be very magnetic
and compelling leader to leader but in
the middle there's a lot of real people
with simple challenges to get through
their day and this obviously is an issue
that is still with you all these years
later yeah
why now to make the movie i mean you
could have made it you've been a movie
maker a director a producer i mean
you've made your own films for a very
long time why at this moment in your
life did you make this movie well yeah
you talked about it very lovingly about
your own parents and i think one of the
things that was
gifted me was my parents uh
belief that their stories were
important to them but not special and
some of the irish dna was to not believe
that your story was more important than
somebody else's often to an extreme
degree so that when we left belfast in a
sort of traumatic situation but we were
a loving family who managed to stay
together and we never ever spoke about
it so 50 years a week
well because the the cardinal sin would
be well you moved to england right yeah
we moved to england and you're irish but
you moved to england yeah is that why
you speak british yeah i guess it is
it's across the i guess it is it's
because it's in them
because i mean
because you know the movie i i started
to watch it and i was like i got to put
on the [ __ ] subtitle because
no really because i mean the irish
accent is pretty heavy it is but it's
also beautiful actually it's beautiful
it is my heritage exactly it has many
many sort of uh complexions to it but
you know one of the things i wanted to
do bill when i when i left is i just
wanted to i left the most amazing
extended family a communal street life
for me it was another beautiful day in
the neighborhood every day and i did not
understand why my friend patty who
happened to be catholic today this
morning was my friend and i could play
with him and this afternoon a man came
and told me i couldn't because he's a
catholic he's got a badge that i
shouldn't approve of that's been messing
with my mind for 50 years so that's why
i wrote it wow if only they
when i was a kid i wish they took me
away from the catholics well how can i
ask mayor question i may ask a question
which is
have you found that
that that that part of your catholic
upbringing
wherever you've arrived at now
has behaviors or a legacy that you still
can't get away from you know that thing
of the jesuits would say show me the kid
till seven and i'll show you the adult
because some of it stay with you and you
and you hate that oh [ __ ] yes i mean
i made a whole movie called religious
i'm bitter
you know i mean it embittered me i was i
had we went to sort of catechism yes or
christ
that was the main subject
well the nuns were married to christ yes
and apparently he was not putting out
because they
[Laughter]
[Applause]
anyway
you